hello I'm Greg Sadler welcome to another
one of my Sadler's honest reviews in
which I do exactly that I give you an
unvarnished competent review of a
generally recent work in philosophy
self-help personal development
leadership could be all those sorts of
things
applied today we actually have a bit of
a double-header
I asked the author Matthew J Van Natta
who I know from a number of different
venues he's quite important in the
modern stoicism movement when his book
The Beginner's Guide to stoicism tools
for emotional resilience and positivity
when this book came out I asked him hey
can you send me a copy for a review and
he not only sent me this book but also
its companion piece the five minutes
stoicism journal and the two works do in
fact go together hand-in-hand so I'm
going to be reviewing both of them and
telling you you know what I think of
each of them they're they're strong
points things that I find problematic
some basic ideas and some summary of the
works themselves the style and the
structure
I'd like to begin by giving you an
overview of the style and the structure
a bit of summary of the works themselves
so we're gonna start with summarizing at
first what kind of books are these so
you might guess from the five-minute
stoicism journal that this is indeed a
journal in which there's a lot of places
for you to do some writing there are in
fact a lot of exercises in here and it's
it this is essentially a workbook but
it's filled with more than just
exercises as we're gonna talk about this
is really the the main book that I would
say this comes out of so the beginner's
guide to stoicism it is exactly that it
is a beginner's guide
it's very nuts-and-bolts it's done in in
such a way as somebody could pick this
up and read through it and understand
quite a few things about not just stoic
doctrine and the system of stoic
philosophy but how to begin applying it
within their own life so that's that's
what these things are intended to do the
style very readable I don't think that
anybody would have trouble making their
way through this that doesn't mean that
that Van Natta has dumbed it down in
fact I think his writing style is in
fact quite good and I enjoyed reading
through this book I'll even say to I I
like the way he's set up these exercises
well we're gonna get to more of that
when we get to the good points about the
book the structure we should talk about
that the books are divided into sections
and chapters so the beginners guide as
you would it well expect has an
introduction there's three parts to it
part one is foundations and there's you
know some introductory stuff there and
then a little bit of historical material
part to your new emotional toolkit
that's one of the central ideas that
that stoicism provides you with a bunch
of tools that go into a toolkit it's got
two sections thinking like a stoic
acting like a stoic and
the much broader section part three
stoicism for life has four chapters
cultivating positivity practicing
emotional resilience being of service
and continuing your journey it has a
good index to it there's a set of
references and resources provided in the
back and what you're gonna find as you
go through this is that each chapter
will have some some discussions some
quotes some reflections or focus points
a lot of things that are kind of bullet
pointed for you and so it's it's done in
a way that you know leads you through it
there's also some exercises that you can
do in this book and then of course
there's exercises in the five-minute
stoicism Journal this one is also
divided into a set of not chapters but
sections and this one is laid out
according to the three disciplines that
epictetus distinguishes in his
discourses
so usually summed up as the discipline
of desire the discipline of action and
the discipline of a sense so the first
section has discipline of desire and
then section two and three our courage
in moderation associated with virtues
we'll talk about that a little bit more
why he does that in a moment
section 4 leads us into the discipline
of action and then we have section 5
focused on the virtue of justice section
6 is the discipline of ascent section 7
the associated virtue of wisdom and then
he brings it to a close with section 8
on emotional resilience connecting back
to the chapter on that in here and
section 9 on sustained happiness and
this book also includes resources and
references so that a person who is
beginning their study as you know the
intended audience of this is could
follow up with that so that is the the
overall you know sort of style structure
summary part for both of these books
together obviously as companion pieces
they share an awful lot in common
you
what are the key ideas of the works I'm
almost tempted to say as Seneca did in
response to his interlocutor who asked
him for a bunch of stoic Maxim's well I
mean the whole thing is full of Maxim's
you know every page practically for this
has some major stoic idea that's being
mentioned or worked out so I'm only
going to give you some high points I
will say this this is something I want a
place very front and center because I'm
going to talk about it both in the good
points and the problematic points of the
work so there is a popular way of
approaching stoicism in the present that
is indebted to epictetus in terms of
these three disciplines
Epictetus himself did not frame the
three disciplines in terms of the
virtues or particular emotions or
anything like that he he mentions the
three disciplines at several points
talks about the third discipline as one
that you know people want to focus on
instead of you know working on the first
two disciplines and epictetus doesn't
actually talk about the virtues quite as
much as the other stoic authors who we
have and the other authors who talked
about stoicism that said that plays a
major role in the organization of this
five-minute stoicism journal and it also
plays a major role in the discussion of
this work the discussions within this
work so we'll come back to that in a
moment and I'll talk about why it's it's
an important set of connections that are
being made let's talk about the virtues
so as vimana brings up quite correctly
the Stoics thought that there were four
cardinal virtues wisdom justice
temperance and courage we can reframe
them as he does with moderation instead
of you know in self-control instead of
temperance but it's all still the same
stuff and these virtues
are you might say baskets in which we
have you know subordinate virtues ways
of being in the world with each other in
in relation to ourselves and these are
things that we want to cultivate the
Stoics in fact thought that the virtues
were the primary good everything else
that was good is good primarily in terms
of virtue so he he does a really good
job in you know highlighting that and
explaining that now understanding what
the virtues are and how they fit into
our lives that is where the the workbook
stuff comes in really well what else
stoicism is something that we we can do
you know in a cognitive way we can learn
about it but it's also incredibly
important that we practice it and that
we do things with it and that we keep
track of ourselves again that's why a
journal is especially useful a
journaling was a stoic practice that was
used by quite a few you know important
people to chart out whether they were
making progress or not figure out what
they needed to focus on analyze the
mistakes that they are making so you
know we're getting a good good
representative sample of what stoicism
is and what it teaches in here we're
also getting very short and kind of
selective history of stoicism in here
which I think can be quite useful for
people to figure out where things fit in
another key idea with stoicism is that
what we are meant for as human beings is
happiness or doing well or flourishing
and that this includes not you know
primarily just you know being filthy
rich or having constant pleasures but
developing the virtues and living a good
life a life that will ultimately be one
with very few negative emotions perhaps
none if we're really really fortunate
right and and we'll have some some good
emotions in there as
well and it'll be a life that flows
along one of the other things that I
think is is good you know both in
stoicism and an Van Nana's treatment of
it is a recognition of the importance of
justice as a virtue and the fact that
the Stoics thought that we are not made
to be you know isolated individuals
withdrawing into our self but rather
connected with other people we're
supposed to be working on improving our
relationships and figuring out you know
how not to be abused but also how to get
out there in the world and take stances
against injustice so that's that's a
very important point we can talk about
that as stoicism as social and then you
know the other thing that I will say one
more time this notion of practices as
being tools and you know putting things
into your toolbox it's kind of a
compelling metaphor
Epictetus seneca marcus aurelius that
you know the big three would talk about
having things ready at hand
meeting practices or insights or Maxim's
or you know judgments and I think that
is quite helpful to think about you know
what are you having ready at hand the
things that actually are tools so those
are a good bit of what's being focused
on in both of these books and the point
of having a toolbox is not just to put
it in the closet for a rainy day
it's to be using these tools all the
time and you know I'll put it to you
this way and this is a good way to close
out this section if you're using these
books as they're intended to be they
ought to get pretty worn out there
they're well put together but they
should get quite a bit of use and
perhaps abuse inadvertently
and that'll be the sign that somebody is
actually making use of these
so I have a lot of good things to say
about these books as books for beginners
but also perhaps to some degree like
this this journal useful for people who
have put in a good bit of progress as
well who've been studying stoicism for a
long time to begin with as I mentioned
before in the Style section these are
very readable and that's something that
can can be challenging in writing about
stoicism because the Stoics actually use
their own technical vocabulary and a lot
of their ideas are rather what we would
call counterintuitive they would call
them paradoxical and so being able to
write about them for a popular audience
in a way that that conveys the
information well and doesn't cut corners
that's actually quite a good thing and I
would say on the whole van natta has
pulled that off now he's got an
incredible advantage if you know who he
is he has had the good fortune podcast
for a long time he was very important in
the development of modern stoicism and
its popularization in in the you know
recent decades so what you've got here
is somebody an author who has been
thinking about and applying these things
for years I mean it's nice - this is a
little bit of a side note that the book
begins in the introduction talking about
his his own story and how stoicism
became useful for him and that gets
brought up again and again in the book
as well so this is somebody to move on
sort of to the next topic this is
somebody who has really thoroughly
studied stoicism who has made it part of
the fabric of his own life thought and
practice and relationships and who now
is providing something for the general
public so that's that's really quite
good it's very competent and you know
for a book that's done in in such little
bite-sized chunks it is a pretty
systematic
presentation of stoic philosophy and
practices so that those are some really
good points another thing that I want to
say is as a high point I spent you know
from somebody who does a lot of work on
the Stoics and with the Stoics both in
scholarly ways and you know in popular
ways and with clients I can say that
that Vinod ah what he has here is a
modern treatment that is really really
grounded in the stoic texts you know
here's here's one way to frame it so
when you're reading through it you're
like well this is not just a bunch of
things all thrown together the way a lot
of the beginner books in stoicism tend
to be this is a really well-thought-out
arrangement and only somebody who is put
in the time and the work and the study
would be able to pull off something that
makes it look this effortless and easy
so again something I think is really
great about it
he's got some some good handling and
interpretation of the disciplines you
know a good example of this and Mark one
is on page 90 where he connects these
three disciplines with what you're going
to be doing in terms of the the notion
of control and what's in your control
and what's not in your control so he's
explaining a bit here the discipline of
desire transfers your affections from
things in life to your virtue how you
walk through life the discipline of
action tells you to stop seeking a
particular end goal and instead make
your best move at every step the
discipline of ascent helps you to
overcome misinterpretations of your
circumstances
so you approach life with clarity now
obviously that's not all that the
disciplines would be doing but you know
what he's got there is actually quite
quite you know quite good it's it's
showing somebody here's how these three
disciplines which seem rather abstract
actually fit in with how you're going to
make your life better
using stoic philosophy so you know
this this is quite excellent I do want
to say something about the notion of the
the three disciplines and the virtues
and connecting it with other things so
Epictetus himself as i mentioned does
not actually make those connections and
you're not going to find the three
disciplines talked about as such prior
to Epictetus as a matter of fact seneca
does talk about three disciplines but
they're not those three disciplines
there there are three other things as
well which can be kind of connected but
but it's not the same thing so you know
where is this ultimately coming from
it's kind of much more modern
interpretation to say let's take the
three disciplines and the four virtues
and bring them together and connect them
with each other in this rather schematic
way now what I want to say about the
good points of that is that some people
who work with that managed to pull it
off
and I think Van Natta does that again
because he's got a really great
grounding in this and has been thinking
this stuff out for years and years and
years so that's all I'm gonna say about
that in the good points stuff the last
thing that I want to bring up is the the
tools in the toolbox the practices so
this book in particular the five minute
stoicism journal has a number of
different practices in it usually
connected with a quote or passage to
help you out and you know some of these
are similar to things that you'll find
in other you know teach yourself
stoicism or you know beginners
introduction and and stuff like that but
I would say just the sheer number of
high quality exercises to do in here all
of which are connected with stoicism
there's nothing in here that's kind of
like make-work or filler this is really
quite good and they're not only
contained in here there are exercises
also contained in in this book as well
so that's pretty impressive and I'm
going to give you one example of
an exercise that I particularly like
that not a lot of people talk about in
there you know let's talk about the you
know practical exercises or practices or
spiritual practices whatever if stoicism
so he's got this discussion that he
calls festival and he starts with a
quotation from Epictetus when you're
alone you should call this condition
tranquility and freedom think of
yourself like the gods and when you're
with many you shouldn't call it a crowd
or trouble or uneasiness but festival
and company and contentedly accept it so
you know epictetus actually goes on he
says you know when the kids come up to
you if their nonsense games you know the
way you're supposed to clap your hands
clap your hands with them you're at a
festival enjoy yourself
right and so venado says I've been at
loud concerts and have had the time of
my life I've been at cafes where one
conversation is slightly too loud and
had my day ruined
Epictetus points out that we give a lot
more grace to people at festivals than
we do to folks on a regular day he
suggests we drop the idea of the crowd
and instead make every day a festival
when the people around you begin to
frustrate you stop take a breath say
festival so you're reminding or some
anomaly connected to incites connected
to behavior connected to emotions he
says think to yourself that this is a
festival these people are my people i
contentedly accept it now that is a
really nicely set up stoic practice I
could take that and dump it into one of
my my classes without changing anything
where I'm introducing students to
philosophy as a way of life and they
could get that and use it right away and
so the reader is going to be able to do
that as well so these are a lot of good
points to the work I think you see where
I'm going with this in terms of
recommending it or not
with pretty much any work you can you
can find something that's problematic
about it and I'm gonna say that the
things that in these works I found
problematic are not problematic with a
uppercase P but a lowercase P and they
might be viewed even as just quibbles so
you know somebody else could read this
and say I'm not really bothered by that
but I do think that there's there's a
few issues that come up and some of that
has to do with my own experience in
working with people who are beginners in
in stoicism so they fall into two main
categories one has to do once again with
something I'd brought up several times
taking the three you know disciplines or
tope way that that Epictetus
distinguishes and the four virtues that
the Stoics talk about and meshing them
into each other in a schematic way now
you can do that and and vinod a-- has
you know showing us that you can do it
quite powerfully pierot doe did that as
well which i think is what gave so many
people the idea that they should do this
it's not non stoic it's just that it's
only one possible way of interpreting
stoicism and it often gets taken by
people as if it's stoic doctrine itself
that these things are connected with
each other and the the point in fact is
that in the ancient stoic texts they
simply aren't so I don't like giving
people the impression that this is not
just an interpretation rather than like
sort of the party line because beginners
in philosophy will tend to begin by
trying to learn whatever they can and
then approaching when they go to the
primary texts they kind of import all
these ideas in and so I've been in so
many stoic sessions whether it's
workshops or small group meetings or
working one-on-one with somebody and
they're like okay so this is this and
this is this and this is this and then
you're like well that's not actually
what
Stoics thought and that's not what the
text say and then like well why did
somebody say that and well they are
trying to give you a summary of it and
some helpful stuff and you took it and
ran with it and I think that's one thing
that can happen with that and you know
my other my other concerns about the the
work basically fall into the same thing
there there are some some aspects to it
some things that are said where
something has been left out obviously
you know book this small you're not
going to have everything included so
these could just be quibbles but I am
going to bring them up so at one point
you know the talks about a modern
therapeutic practice cognitive behavior
therapy was influenced by stoic writing
so that's completely true but cognitive
behavior therapy was influenced by it
because rational emotive behavior
therapy developed by Albert Ellis was
explicitly influenced by epictetus and
by stoicism so you know I think it would
have been good to say something about
that I I'm not sure about this assertion
that the dichotomy of control like Van
Natta says of all the stoic tools you
will receive that Academy of Control is
the most fundamental I don't think that
there is a single fundamental practice
or idea or anything for stoicism I think
there's a number of different ones and
they all kind of hang together but you
know again we could say well that's
that's my interpretation rather than his
the claim that Epictetus developed the
discourses
historically we don't really know that
that's the case as a matter of fact
given how conservative Epictetus
is in so many other ways it's probable
that he got these from somewhere else we
we don't have them in the lectures of
his teacher mo so Gnaeus Rufus but then
again we don't have a lot of what Rufus
perhaps wrote or taught and so we're not
really sure and and I should I should
say Van Natta
doesn't make a strong claim here he says
the three disciplines seemed to have
been developed by epictetus both to
inform stoy practice and act as a
structure for his school's curriculum
so that's that's you know good to talk
about as well and think about there's
another thing where you know there's
somebody left out in in the story and
that is an important writer who we learn
a lot about stoicism from and he's being
used here in the book for example in the
section on courage breaking down the
virtue of courage into five different
sub virtues because there's other ways
of breaking it down in the stoic
literature endurance confidence
high-minded cheerfulness industriousness
that's coming from arias didymus who is
not being mentioned at all in the
history or in the references so you know
there it'd be nice to see that in there
in part because that text is so helpful
for other people when they want to go on
but I think they did encounter it anyway
so these are again really minor points
and and I don't think that they detract
in any major way from the work I just
think that you know when people are
studying stoicism we do got we do have
to make sure that they're getting to the
to the primary textual material from
these gateways and you know once they do
if they are reading things into it
hopefully they eventually get to the
point where where what they're reading
is is less informed by what they're
bringing in from the outside and more by
the text it's often then they can come
back to stuff like this and say this is
actually quite quite good
for people who are interested in
stoicism and are at a beginner level and
perhaps even some at a intermediary
level I would actually highly recommend
both of these books The Beginner's Guide
to stoicism quite good it's you know
very small you can carry it around it's
it's you know quite durable as well I've
already put it through some paces a
little pricey at $12.99 a book but I
think that's that's that's well within
the normal range the five-minute
stoicism journal this you know I think
if you actually use it the way it's
intended to this is a book that you'll
get a lot of mileage out of and it'll
help you develop insights it's full of
really great exercises 1499 for for this
one so all told you can get you know
both of these for less than 30 bucks and
this you know would be a good course
these could in fact be used for groups
that are studying stoicism these could
be used with with some supplements as
kind of textbooks I think so I think
they're really quite good for somebody
who's at you know in the intermediate
intermediary level and start you know
really studying a lot of stuff all the
way to the advanced level okay this
might not be as useful it depends on you
know what you want to do with it but I
think this could still be quite handy
I'm very happy that I've got a copy
so my overall recommendation is that you
get a hold of these if you if you don't
have them already
you